congratulations Selena on this beautiful
film I know you said you've been nervous
to have it out there for the world but
you really are going to change so many
lives with this and for people to not
feel alone by sharing your journey how
healing has this been for you in a weird
way I feel like it is it's a time
capsule of a period of my life where I
look back and I actually feel bad for my
that version of myself and I I think
that it was good for me to see how I was
responding to my body the way I was
acting and the way it was so irrational
at moments and I think it was really
healing for me to see that and get it
out I think so yeah being so open about
your mental health journey in particular
what would you tell a younger Selena who
may have been too afraid to ask for help
while she was struggling and that may
help someone now I think my advice is to
not be afraid I never actually was
afraid to to tell people that I want to
take time for myself I never thought
that was a bad thing so to be sharing to
be sharing something honest and saying
hey I'm taking a break because I need it
I'm being honest and I think that's just
who I am honestly last question for you
at the end of the documentary we hear a
beautiful new single of yours my mind in
me which is a very Personal Diary of
yours would you like to put more of your
Diaries into music I think ideally that
is the goal is being able to write these
stories that are happening in my life
now because it's been years since I've
released music so so many beautiful
things have happened and I can't wait to
tell that through music and being able
to be your most authentic self thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign